for a man whose life and career were a
continuing soap opera
it was a fittingly dramatic final
journey
the body of diego maradona on the way to
the cemetery
people climbing metal fences to witness
a moment of history
there had been suggestion of a state
funeral but plans were hastily changed
as fears rose over mass gatherings
a life lived in technicolor at full
throttle and maximum volume
but at the end there was peace for
maradona laid to rest in a private
ceremony beside his parents
[Applause]
buenos aires a city overwhelmed by
coronavirus
is now overcome by grief
they waited for hours to enter the
presidential casa rasada
inside maradona's body lay in state
the president alberto fernandez placing
his famous number 10 shirt on the casket
he lived almost an entire life in the
public glare
and even in death he's in demand some
through shirts others held young
children a lot to catch a glimpse
one man so weakened by emotion he
struggled to stand
up he went full circle
i have taught my children diego story
and i come from baha'i blanca to say
goodbye
diego gave me the happiest moment of my
life
to comprehend this adoration you have to
appreciate the path
travelled maradona grew up in a
three-bedroom shack in one of the city's
most dangerous slums
where the only running water was a leak
in a corrugated iron roof
from abject poverty he became the
world's greatest footballer
but remained one of their own it's quite
extraordinary the the madness that
surrounds him wherever he walks wherever
he goes and
we're seeing it now as as a nation
grieves and mourns
um the passing of of their absolute
sporting hero
on the pitch the 1986 world cup win was
maradona's crowning glory
the single greatest tournament
performance by any footballer
and it won't be forgotten here the first
of three days of national mourning
brought
thousands to the streets the debate over
who is the finest footballer of them all
will continue
but certainly none have caused a
religious-like devotion
in the same way as diego maradona martha
kellner
sky news